The Joe Rogan Experience because I have
a 19 year old daughter and
um she's amazing and she is not like if
if
if I brought up the idea of her pursuing
a career based on Financial Security she
would be offended and I and I say that
with a little bit of a joke because
I also remember like the comedians
people that go into comedy are not like
you know we didn't know it was going to
be this type of business we went into it
because it was uh you know creatively
fulfilling to get on stage and make
strangers laugh and but like there is
something at least for me having five
kids it's like I really didn't care
about money
uh you know in my 30s
I remember my parents died and people
were pick you know like we all my
siblings came around we were getting
stuff and I was like I'll take the
immigration papers you guys can have the
rest and so like I was the youngest but
like the point I'm getting to as you get
older
once you get a taste for Comfort
it's you know because I've tried to
articulate to my children you know money
is about Freedom you know it's like the
freedom to like afford to go on a date
you know the the freedom of Independence
like I don't have to ask mom and dad for
my help for help and so but there is a a
you know the perspective that changes
I'm not saying all people but like when
you're 20
all right do I have enough money to get
beer you know what I mean as opposed to
like when you're 40 you're like all
right I might need knee replacement
surgery do you know what I'm saying yeah
and like there is some
you know comforts you like Comforts
right you don't want to struggle right
and you don't want to be scared as to
where your next paycheck's coming from
yeah I mean I I fly you know commercial
and I fly uh you know business class and
it's amazing and I don't you know like
if I have a gig and they're like you
know
I'd you know I would have to
uh fly and Coach I don't know if I want
to do it
like I'm kind of a
you know it's like is it worth being
really uncomfortable for a bunch of
hours like I have like I live in New
York and I work at UH
um the win has wins a great casino right
and they have this theater and it's a
great thing and
so there used to be all these direct
flights from New York
that I mean there's tons but there were
some live flat things and they were like
live flat yeah so like were you you know
it's like the seat turns into a bed oh
lie flat and so from New York it's like
a five hour flight and so they
essentially started getting rid of those
things and if I want to perform in Vegas
anymore
I got
I got flat I'll do that anyway
I'm just trying to impress everyone with
my uh my toughness my mental grit baby
can't a baby can't be uncomfortable for
a couple hours you can definitely get
used to comfort yeah
yeah but it's probably not good for kids
to grow up that comfortable no it's
interesting you know it's like we all
everyone that I know that's interesting
had a pretty shitty childhood and rough
and difficult and a lot of problems and
but none of those people want that for
their children even though it made them
the most interesting people that I know
because they got through some hard times
and difficult childhoods and struggle
and they developed discipline and
character and you know the ability to
overcome adversity I mean it is if
parenting is terrifying it is it's
terrifying it's a complicated world
because you know you're gonna suck at it
but it's like how much damage can you do
yeah yeah and how much damage does the
world do yeah yeah it's not just you
it's like what are your children getting
exposed to at school what are your
children get exposed to on the streets
yeah because when they they reach a
certain age where like you can hear them
actively not listening to and you're
like oh I hope your peer group
is communicating some of this stuff
because I've said it six times and
you're obviously not hearing it you know
I mean yeah it's really and it's when
you know when you have young kids you
think oh because I think our society we
kind of portray
you know babies Oh I couldn't sleep last
night my baby was crying I had to change
poopy diapers and that's the easy part
that's the easy yeah that's just lack of
sleep yeah
but like when it's Saturday night and
they're out and you're like what where
are they right going to parties it's
terrifying yeah and who knows what's
happening at these parties